want you and Chloe to be okay and happy  and connected Kris Jenner is playing  peacemaker for Robin Chloe on this  Sunday's Keeping Up with the Kardashians  it would be so easy if you would just  make the first move I get it  I'll reach out to pose that's your  brother the drama over Rob's  relationship with blac Chyna has been a  major storyline this season though the  family is on good terms with the model  now we're all in a good place  another family member who's in a good  place Kendall after her stalker scare  this month 20 year-old joked about the  commotion the situation caused when she  swung by Jimmy Kimmel on Wednesday night  and get this Jimmy also happens to be a  her neighbor our neighbors are like were  up in arms when you moved on to the  block oh there was a whole thing with  emails that went on yeah bad yeah I mean  oh you got there a lot of like ruckus on  her Kendall was granted a temporary  restraining order against the alleged  stalker last week